you may not know the name ifelu but you
will because disney's mulan starts
streaming tomorrow on disney plus
and only we got to join the rising star
on set
in new zealand i don't want to put too
much pressure on you
but you're mulan
have you prepared yourself for the fame
and the fans there's also pressure
oh that's right three two 1
director nikki cairo knew right away she
had found her mulan
and ifelu felt a special connection to
the legendary warrior
the reason why mulan can get this far
is because she had this faith and hope
yeah and love she fight for love
insult me again you'll taste the tape
off my blade
lower your sword finding the right man
to play mulan's love interest well that
took a bit longer but it was worth the
wait for yosen
on so my first tape was two years ago
and i didn't hear back for like a whole
year for a call back
oh my god both stars endured three
months of rigorous training and they
found out
who is the toughest i passed out at
least two or three times no you didn't
legit yeah every time of course that
just reinforces the message of mulan
female empowerment just be true to who
you are and
you're as powerful if not more powerful
than
any other man out there preach
you